there's one thing that SM Smugglers
often talk about
is you never get high in your own
Supply but I broke that Golden
Rule dad gave me the joint and I had a
couple of Puffs on that and I thought
well this is something special this
stuff all the stress started to leave my
body and I thought yeah this is
beginning feel
good it was very hot it was a bit Smoky
and I decided to go outside the door and
look out the window from the other side
it'd be nice and
cool there was one God who I saw when I
entered onto the training and he come
down the
corridor and when he approached me he
pointed to his nose
so I just put it
out sorry about that and he continued to
walk on I turned around and I just
looked at him he looked at
me I had a rush of
panic if you identified the smell of
cannabis that would have been enough to
attract them to Sears to can
I just hadn't running mother God what
one minute we're happily stoned then the
next minute the severity of the
situation sort of hits
you we were sitting on 20 kilos of
cannabis and it was very easy to
find and so we just waited and
dread it was tense
and uncomfortable and a lot of paranoia
running through
US Open up I'll deal with that
right I was a bit dubious but I let Dad
sort of make that choice I let him make
that
call was the same God who had St on the
corridor and my heart started to sort of
palpitate a little bit what do you
want give me
what I know that he's just a a train
guard and so I hand him a packet of
forign
cigarettes he looked at them and
pocketed them but didn't
leave and I thought to myself what's
going on here what what is he looking
for money or
what so I reached into my pocket I
pulled out a bit of really good quality
Afghan Paul in hash and it's running
through my head well if I hand him this
over he'll probably think this is the
last of my
stash and I handed them
that that's all I
got op he said no don't be serious opium
no no way is this opium and he said this
looks like opium to me and he said
listen no it's not opium trust is 100%
not
opium he sniffed it put it into his
pocket and I thought well that's great
now he's happy with what he's got but
didn't
leave the only thing in my mind was how
can I get rid of this guy he wants some
cash no no no TI it and I just looked at
him
and we're thinking wow what the hell's
going on here give me
ticket he really wanted that train
ticket there was no other option I
handed him over my
ticket and he looked at the ticket and
put that in his pocket and then
left